[Música]
[Aplausos]
foi durante toda a noite
o amigo quer começar por fazer alguns
agradecimentos alimentos a alternext
flamengo que entenda convidado enfim
estava à espera
ao fim destes anos todos ter feito todas
as provas técnicas acadêmicas negócios
etc
faltava um facto isto desafio é que sabe
pra mim foi uma motivação e tal como
também foi de certa forma lindo enfim
algo inspirador para mim preparar é esta
é a apresentação vai nos falar como foi
dito
anda a relação entre engenharia e água
na perspectiva principal das alterações
climáticas esperando que isso possa ser
feito também um pouco como foi mostra
motivadora e e inspiradora assim pra
todos vocês enfim como o ers desse
problema que eu vou apresentar não podia
também deixar de enfim voltar aqui esta
magnífica ansiedade
trinta anos depois de ter saído em fita
da escola aqui para agradecer a todos os
estudantes professores e com os quais eu
tenho a oportunidade de lidar e
transformou base e foram a motivação e
inspiração para tudo que eu fiz nos
últimos 30 anos se ao movimento esquecer
a minha mãe que foi minha primeira
pessoa
bom eu vou lhe falar e dirigiria há
várias formas de inserir várias
engenharias
mas enfim acho que pro gol só o
movimento quer falar de uma forma mais
objetiva e concreta de engenharia civil
que é digamos daquilo e na qual é o
trabalho nos últimos 30 anos entanto foi
a licenciatura que tirei em 1989 tanta
isso que eu sai eles que eu saí falar em
engenharia civil tem várias áreas do
conhecimento
tenho orientado
apenas uma determinada área os factos de
civil tanto lida com grandes estruturas
como onde de garagens como lida com as
vias de comunicação as grandes
autoestradas as grandes vias de
comunicação deve estar a falar do
planeamento do território conhecimento
da água deve estar a falar de questões
geotécnica são todas as infra estruturas
são o centro da terra o terreno deve
estar a falar da hidráulica entanto
deixar o último mas essa aqui é a minha
paixão no início do trabalho
nos últimos 30 anos mas de facto as
várias vertentes da engenharia civil que
o que aumenta o frio mas são várias mas
todas elas têm um ponto em comum que é
água e portanto é um problema que mais
tarde ou mais cedo essas áreas sobre
áreas do conhecimento dele seria bom ter
cuidado com elas
bom também não poderia se não fizesse
uma breve referência à escola um
trabalho que a faculdade do estado porto
é melhor faculdade de engenharia do país
enfim trabalho neste campo lá desde 2001
tenha começado a trabalhar na rua dos
bragas na antiga faculdade também muito
particular enfim sendo a área da
hidráulica também gostaria de mostrar o
maior laboratório de hidráulica
universitário do país que é o meu
trabalho e tenho prazer de dirigir e
onde está incluído o trabalho maior
tanque de ondas universitários do país
bom enfim não foi para isso que eu vim
aqui falar e falar de água e da relação
da água com regeria um aspecto
particular das alterações climáticas
eu gosto de pensar enfim várias das
minhas palestras aulas
sou o flyer quilos tanto o enquadramento
em água no mundo
nós vamos pensar de fato há muita água
que existe muita água mas enfim se
reservas de água doce ficava em uma
pequena esfera de 700km israel tanto
embora o volume da água seja
significativo é apenas dois e meio por
cento desse volume da água é que é água
doce e desses dois e meio por cento
apenas 13% está na forma líquida
aquela vai terminar qual nós temos
acesso e 10 3% é apenas 2% é que está o
que existe à superfície nós apenas temos
acesso direto é essa pequena porcentagem
de agosto isto é muito importante porque
vamos fazer isto mais à frente
bom o que é que problemas é que nós
queremos servir directamente esta
questão da água no futuro o fórum
econômico mundial
agora todos os anos com vitórias sobre
fibra de sistemáticas
é importante verificar enfim que
recorrentemente nos últimos anos a
questão das crises de água e dos eventos
extremos associados e todos os eventos
extremos associações a falar das
inundações das cheias dos sexos tempo
estado de 77 ato de respeito à água
sabia dizer que as rotatórias
recorrentemente nos últimos anos refere
que cuidar desses eventos temos viria a
ocorrer com maior freqüência no futuro é
cada vez maior e isso tem obviamente
consequências de caráter social e
económica em que serão cada vez maior
no entanto estão um aspecto que nos deve
preocupar para o futuro
quando olhamos para o consumo da água no
mundo e este grave o bastante
elucidativo em termos de bacia
hidrográfica nós vemos ali pelas manchas
mais escuras onde é que esse consumo da
água é maior o problema cópias e quando
enfim deveríamos ou quando comparamos
consumo com esses cuidados e olhando
trecho novo gráfico as zonas mais escuro
aposentam zonas onde de fato quase
consome toda a água ontem
esporadicamente e água falta ocorrendo
prius é que enfrentar um período de
escassez desse recurso é e tanto isso é
algo que ocorre nos dias de hoje e
incidiria a ciência
e eu dizia investigação está muito
preocupada com o que vai acontecer no
futuro o que vai acontecer daqui no ano
2050 em 2006 entanto fazer previsões
para esse foi o tempo mais alargado e
uma das principais preocupações atuais é
a questão das alterações climáticas
enfim a quem acredita quem não acredita
enfim há evidências claras da sua
resistência e está em impacto direto no
digamos na questão da água disponível e
como os fenômenos relacionados com a
água estão a passar no futuro a uma
instituição muito importante trabalhar
nisso nesse aspecto as alterações
climáticas que o painel
intergovernamental para as alterações
climáticas e periodicamente faz suas
previsões para o futuro com o que aquilo
vai a conselho na superfície da terra
estamos a falar em termos da alteração
da temperatura média da superfície do
planeta mas também questões como a
avaliação ao longo do tempo no futuro
das precipitações ou seja de chuva
propriamente dita e essas previsões são
feitas com vários cenários cenários mais
otimistas nas mais pessimistas e esses
cenários mais otimistas ou mais
pessimistas tem essencialmente a ver com
a quantidade de emissões que nós
lançamos para a atmosfera tanto o
chamado efeito de estufa quanto mais
quanto menores forem essas desse
lançamento e filtrar um cenário mais
otimista quanto maior for a previsão de
lançamento
pior mais pessimistas trará esse cenário
então nós olhamos para prestígio gráfica
ea vossa esquerdo tem os cenários mais
otimistas
a vossa direito de os cenários mais
pessimistas em cima estamos a falar da
temperatura média da superfície do globo
e podemos constatar que enfim quero
no cenário mais otimista que no cenário
mais pessimista enfim podemos ter
variações da temperatura média do ar à
superfície do planeta e paulo goulart
entre 1 graus antigo até aos 4 5 6 graus
centígrados e suavemente para ter um
impacto na precipitação que vai ocorrer
sobre o planeta
hum em termos um cenário mais otimista
só em termos de cenário mais pessimista
então nós podemos facilmente identificar
zonas
enfim mais o laranjada sou mais
avermelhadas onde vai ocorrer uma
redução significativa da percentagem de
precipitação que ocorrem em média por
ano
e também teremos ônus enfim mais voado
sem ter essa porcentagem irá aumentar
tanto estão as provisões em termos de
alterações climáticas são assinados com
a precipitação média anual
enfim já para um horizonte está com 11
pontos a favor dele saem
atualmente nós temos cá nós mas enfim
alguém estar a entrar a cuidar com este
com este problema
bom é este este esquema mostra também
essa possível variação em termos de
precipitação pode ocorrer no globo
embora para o horizonte não querem mais
próximo em 2050 e temos facto verificar
que enfiar zonas em que vai ocorrer uma
diminuição significativa dessa
precipitação média anual mas enfim
também haverá outras zonas onde essa
precipitação média anual irá aumentar
bom nós obviamente estamos preocupados
aqui com nosso retângulo com o nosso
cantinho e finanças da ue e um caminho
viável tanto significa que de facto as
previsões não serão muitos famosos para
o futuro
mas enfim também não é caso para grande
mesmo sendo digamos um zoom mais para
europa ficou novamente estamos situados
também em termos de precipitação média
anual está as provisões para para para o
futuro enfim nós temos verificar que
enfim o sul da europa quer em termos
médios anuais quer no verão e irá sofrer
uma redução significativa dessa
precipitação anual tanto no fundo aquilo
que já tinha mostrado anteriormente mas
enfim fazendo uma análise mais detalhada
para a europa e isso vai ter novamente
outras repercussões em termos do prius
cecam das previsões para o final
do século estamos a falar de dois mil e
saem é que pegamos o índice de dom de
deus para para a europa fique com os
pondo fim a uma idéia certa forma a
quantidade de chuva que pode ficar
detida no sol
enfim mostra que podemos ter nos
próximos até o final do século uma área
mais significativa sujeita apreendidos
do séc
tudo isso são simulações de modelos
matemáticos avançados em que usam
informação anos anteriores décadas
anteriores e com base em estimativas de
emissão de gases de efeito estufa para a
atmosfera e fazem previsões a médio
longo prazo para 2050 e 2000 e sair
dessa informação é útil para o cidadão
comum o cidadão em geral também para os
políticos por decisões para poder o
movimento tomar medidas nesse sentido
bom vai acontecer é que em fibra zonas
no globo enfim em particular a princípio
era aquela que mais nos interessa onde é
curto prazo
a falta d'água irá ocorrer aliás
estima-se que nos próximos anos estamos
a falar de 2025 também é muito hoje
cerca de dois mil e cinco mil milhões de
pessoas são afetadas por este fenômeno
da falta de água
bom mas será que isso realmente está a
acontecer enfim acreditar que não
acredita em algumas evidências existe há
muitos dados e portanto esses dados
ilustram precisamente essas evidências
eu trago aqui um caso muito simples que
nos mostra qual é que tem sido a
precipitação média em portugal
enfim nos últimos 30 anos antes do ano
2000 eo etá são estas colunas é azul
claro mas o o os bairros mas vou escuro
representam aconteceu no último ano nós
fato fazemos uma comparação que podemos
dizer
tchau e alguns meses onde a precipitação
é próxima dessa média dos 30 anos que
está indicado mas nitidamente a valores
estão completamente díspares do que
aconteceu nesse período 30 anos tanto
isso é uma evidência dessa alteração em
termos climatéricos em termos de
precipitação e provavelmente resultado
das alterações climáticas e também da
variabilidade climática o movimento
bom o que nós estamos a fazer em relação
a esta questão da gestão da água e como
é que nós não estamos eventualmente
adaptar continuamente essa questão das
alterações climáticas bom nos dias de
hoje
nós captamos a água que gastamos milhões
de euroso tratar essa é a água
distribuímos água pelas pessoas
os consumidores e depois voltamos a tal
agora estamos outra vez milhões de euros
que depois ser novamente lançada no meio
hídrico e sempre o aumento voltar mais
tarde a ser captada e todo esse processo
enfim substituir forma cíclica entanto
sempre estarmos mais milhões de milhões
de euros em todo este processo que tanto
no futuro e em função dessas alterações
climáticas
o volume da água que o tráfego consumido
tem que se reduzir drasticamente e uma
forma de isso acontecer como já acontece
em algumas cidades do mundo
é que nesta questão do ciclo urbano da
água quando estes ciclos acabei de falar
é que esse curso seja mais chave ou seja
que haja um melhor aproveitamento da
água entrando naquilo que hoje em dia se
estuda e está muito em voga que é
economia circular de água tanto
aproveitar mais a utilizar mais e com
isso em termos uma diminuição
significativa dos custos para o cidadão
e também para o estado só por
curiosidade
numa cidade como por exemplo cingapura
praticamente circula sempre quis entrar
água consome também por razões
geográficas e pelas próprias
características da cidade de cingapura
e água na lua bom fiz foi uma provocação
que eu vou introduzir na minha
apresentação enfim sem entrar em litígio
com o colega que falou no início pelo
erro mas basicamente para ilustrar que
os professores em relação à água não se
confinam apenas a terra e fato as
agências espaciais enfim desde sempre
está em preocupavam em tentar perceber
tentar saber em tentar descobrir se são
de facto de estar a água fora da terra
está água na lua ou até noutros planetas
e fatos recentemente essa notícia surgir
mas enfim isso permitiria ter bases
permanentes instaladas na lua permite
antever consumo humano dessa água se
formou com ltda da floria permitirá um
ponto permitir enfim a produção do
oxigênio para tornar a pressionar o
artigo vamos mais respirável e também
produzir hidrogênio como fonte de
combustível
bom enfim para terminar
depois de tudo o que lhes enfim que a
motivação é que eu o que cada um de
vocês é bom ter em relação a este
problema avançam água e diria ou
alterações climáticas
bom é importantíssimo que a defesa deste
recurso água enquanto recurso à água
seja atendida enquanto um bem escasso
fim já temos que esquecer em algumas
zonas vai aumentar
cada um de nós tem um papel muito
importante nessa função em vários países
principalmente os países mais pobres a
falta d'água é crítica
o desperdício e enfim é recorrente em
vários e vários países constituição e
ousadíssimo e anunciado por para e
reutilizar para entrarmos naquilo que eu
sofri como uma economia circular é
também fundamental
finalmente enfim a ter confiança nem
deveria ter confiança na capacidade de
provisão destes fenômenos do que vai
acontecer no mundo para o futuro e bom
em último caso se expulsar aquecer muito
assustada correu mal e
é uma oportunidade que a lua está
obrigado a salvar tal máscara preta
estava irã quinto